[音楽]
yeah
ん
みなさーーー
初めましてん
は the year
うぉ
影響
夢希望に満ちあふれた皆さんの前でお話
できることを本当に嬉しく思っています
みてくださいハーフサリー
さて私が今回この素晴らしいオファーを
いただいた時
1して炎台
リッパー員があります
聞いたのにっ
私の中でひとつになるぱねぇ芸
言葉がありました
それは去っ os 遠方すごはん亭むつ
わん
聞いたことありますがこの頃
いません
実際超昂みたいな流れ
何事も成し遂げるまで成功するまでは不
可能に思えというかさ
この言葉は
皆さん年のに
何で割っ
ですねっ
アバラぱふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇ
ふぇパン尽力しのルーション称した世界的
に著名な政治からありをしてみましたただ
の言葉です
私はの言葉もすごくパン普通に提出は自分
のラフトップの水性版にしているほどなん
ですね
そして芝本に
てリーガーイチロー正当性こんなにパンツ
類の市場などん思った時には実はともに
座っ目指すん
おういえ私はそんなに以来なことは何も
出したわけではないんですけど
ただ
コナン
黄金すごい音千代一パン
これ言葉胸に二寸座のでどのように
多さイーオスも見ますえっ
落ち目感ん
っていうところ超恥ずかしいお話しした
もの
さてまず
を離させな臭いものんをっ
カラー
いいパースポンということがあっ
皆さんも何検出されました
だと普通の子というような少年になること
もあると思います
ただ同時にのという言葉だけでなく
例えばさあっ
失敗難しさというようなシチュエーション
にも落ちた得るのではないかな
皆さんもですねちょっとずっと考え
ご自身の経験の中で砂ん日本戦を思うか
ベアパンした瞬間
ちゃいどんなものがありましたか
いろいろが見ます
私の今回のこのファンとなるに考えてみ
ましたん
いろいろあります
そんな自分の経験を元にちょっとお話今
から37番
[音楽]
まず
コア5ぽせもんの自分のベースとなる3
ラン
おそらく私が10代だっ
何回戦です
私の重大どんなものが完売
私はですね日本の関西という西日本の地域
のある攻撃の町で育ちました
当時は中古ん6年間一旦のくらいループ
救う女子校が学校に通い
私が回るん学的裕福な
a 子供爆風そう言ったら校に行きました
と比較した一般 the 一般商品のです
ね私はそのり結構いろんな
良くも悪くもカルチャーショックを指示を
受けながら
ただすごく杏んー
整備されるん
そしてとても安心できるそういったこと
だった環境が当たる前というような環境で
生活を知ったんですね
そんなときに一つ大きな
チャレンジがありますそのに多分トーン
当時私はまだ中学校そう年生だったとき
自分の父親
あ
病に倒れる
突然です本当に突然でした
そして彼はその後約10年パン
一度の自宅に帰ることがなく
入寮したまま
そしてその後最終的に一緒
その人生音とするということに
保ちの私は
今後父がローラー6
[音楽]
数信号手だった母そして一人っ子の話を
通してたまらけどのもう本当に心配ふわ
ですよね
今でも思い出せます
どうぞ
そして私もその当時できなかったこと
自分のその2はどうしてもそうだ
どうしたら結成してしまうパ
またすぐにも十分苦労しているとなりの
母親にこれー者の審判をかけたくなると
思ってしまう
そして自分なりに考えてみたんですね
そして消しただした切断
何がたかというと
アメリカに留学をします突然です r 治り
ある good stay
正直この決断には自分の2件っていうのも
ありましたもうここは教わったぞ逃げも
ありましたん当時の私はこの日夜の状況に
まっしょん meaning トーン
地震
まああまりが葉っぱ風の事実です
ああ
あなたの市の支援高くの
この心臓5ライドされが張らないという
状況から無線を変えたんですね
なんだれてるよな
そしてそのときに自分の思います
この状況そして今サバイブする部分は事実
は実をつけなければいたら
そのために
女芸人
当時私はプラスですね前ごろコスは今いい
入れたコラム
そしてそれを強い買いにサバイブして
いこうと思ったも現地に行ってもちろん
なカナダフランスの花が入ったをれるよう
なこともありました
皆さんも語学を今ここで恋情する方が多い
と思うのでそんないろんな苦しいがあると
思います
源氏いた母
不二家
ジャンプ増やしたのはたくさんありました
まだ
まずは
ses のん直井手段
なんていっ
まあこれは盟友の姉が生まれるんですよ飯
テロソンミン
メールも復旧していない
そんな時代です皆さんちょっとイメージし
にくいかもしれないね
ただその中で自分が何をしたん
さあこれまた藤井ずに塗りでできるぞ
eme
新しいアクティビティ1本見ます活動に
参加してみる
雪白のチャンスを無駄にしないん
自分はこの自分を決めた
この大きなた援助
いっぱいこのチャンスイスルパン
もう私は何が何度も
かおりません
ブブー
一度3
あっ
そうしたステッパーステップをにペン
3周的に結果としては
私は当時の済みてダウンしたいっ
英語丸ならず
パーソナリティの伝わったと思います
より前向きにボス
そしてナンバー
自分で
解決していく
そういったところを身に着ければそんな
経験はそこで埋まるかと思います
そこからスピンは
パーペン
ここでキャリアの話1する者と思います
19や私のチェジャですね
したことで商品するかっ
yes インユーザー
自分でいろんなチャレンジャ
決断すまさ
どんなものがあっ
夏山ぞ落ちてあげるッパポイントなぁと
思います一つ
大学の卒業まっ外して社会人
そしてそこ年
手順
8ありは
グリッパーまー坊のホスピタリティ栄養
たいにゃぶはち
を低減します
すごく順風満帆今様側でチャレンジん
その業界をを部分 a新しいチャレンジ中
歳ということで全く異なる上官に移します
そこでは
リクルーティング
人生車たいな4期に移ります0 a
スタートですなーかーずー5倍になってい
ます
から
作用
少し一歩スープ
がんばってくうせっ
なんだなおめつ目は自分で作った新しい
三枝
何例えば
じゃあ生活する場所働く場所と興味嘘
デュー cae をみー
のような大きな舞台ででうまくんだって
新しい社員
あっ
ています
東京の生活の中なん
在庫リーズなんかじゃあ2弾チャンジョマ
それはまた
仕事の間ペン次は
じいじのん
さ八段分
いうヘアチェンジ
をしません
そして私は今
9分シージャジャーン
うん
最初の神自分が採用ちん
いきます
赤間当時でいうとですねプライベートでは
結婚してっ
リクもし
なかったんですね
まあ本当に忙しいそんな20年は半から
3003というような
をチャレンジと本当にが新しい挑戦が
たくさんあるよそんなところでしたんただ
これが2ちゃん2していることっていうの
は全て自分で決めたちゃん in ん
ずっぱというと証言的には自己責任
という言葉にターンとかもあるかもしれ
ないですが私はいとこ
the
あっ言う
ザズー
守られてきた10台分
学生だった頃の社会人大きく違います須賀
くん自分自身
ダンバルも1貼らないの
自分次第と言うとか
その気持ちはまばにん
私は今のはおかげさまでこのチーフ分シー
ジャパン分間車
えさ4チームをリーダーをぬそんな
素晴らしいの婦人読む
そしてこの上ない素晴らしいメンバー富士
山のなくなっ
さあいたところ meme
そんなジュンブん
じゃあこんな
てるよねいろいろ自分で決断をしていたん
いろいろ経験を知った二苦しいことも
たくさんありました
それを踏まえて皆さん長にお伝えしたい
こと
みっ
を見ます
一つ目
伊那皆さん座ってらっしゃるとなりを
見渡してみてください
自分の周りにいる
友人家族恋人
またこうした学校や歯医者で北関東を新た
な陰湿そこに感謝をするということ
つい
心臓に何かチャレンジであるので失敗した
ときのは
こういうことも一つのチャレンジですよね
最後の上に
[拍手]
強く人を割るんですね
そうですそこでお手製が入ってたのはまあ
動くおっ
オアババール
数字分でアーム2人どんどん押してもまあ
私もそう用いています
ただ同時に
忘れないでいただきたいなぁ周りが環境
存在している友人家族の反射数分そして
とき彼らに対してサポートをお願いする
アドバイスをするしてもらうということの
ok ね
ちょっと私はまだそこが
や腹でできないかなというところでもあり
ます
ただいろいろな
一人じゃないんだとか
パパ
ん
お花君っていうことですね経験の中でも
話しましたん
しばざ
アーロン
例えばステップバックしてい
物事を見てい
そうするとです思いがけないところに審判
答えがあったりします
またときに息抜きをするというのも大事
です
そうすることでまた相手の中2-4解決
ファンを見つければいいん
私のファイティングついつい
何でしまっている銀ちゃんということです
がこれを過ぎてるんですね新しい
アイディアが浮かぶという前に飛躍だなっ
ちゃうこともあるのでこれは皆さんに余る
おすすめします
さて冗談はさておき2あと3つ目
マミ多分あっ
成功体験小さな成功体験をつくって自信に
変えるということです
有名な
そこだ日本もいます
ファン本
鈴はん
今派
聞いたございます
うん
秋に苦しい時にはさんをどころかずっぱし
付きましているっていうような気持ちも
あると思います
ほら
そんなたちはぜひ行っだ後ろを振り返って
も見えません実は一歩進んでいるかもしれ
ん
どんな小さな梯子に立ったとしても
少し前進実は声優ん
この c は私の本当に絨毯で強く心から
本呈する母親
まを知っ
この3点を私は今日皆さんを伝え脅ししっ
そして本当に夢と希望に満ちあふれた皆
さん
これからいろんなチャレンジもあると思い
ます
バラー
そこに常に性行大検をつくって苦しい土地
が正サポートまがあ
そして前に
バンバンパンチェンジをしています
まずなっ
大六星新報さはアン013
ぜひ2名ね1本前進します
ありがとうございました
[拍手]